well i'm going to bring you back to the
16th century first the italians
especially were interested in cubic
polynomial x cubed
plus oh 5x
plus 7. something of that sort
now i'll draw you the graph
of any of these cubic polynomials let us
say i'll draw it uh qualitatively unless
you're particularly perverse in your
choice of cubic polynomial it's going to
look sort of like that it's kind of
distinctive wiggle there's a wiggle
there there's a it looks like it's
counting to a maximum and then it uh
changes its mind and it uh then it goes
to a
dip there and then it thinks oh gosh
this is a valley and
especially if the uh coefficient of the
x cube is positive it'll go
off to
in to plus infinity and otherwise it
will be reversed
i'll draw you a few of them now you
might say why did i
call this a few of them
rather than just one
the reason is i haven't told you where
the x-axis is
and i can change my cubic polynomial by
adding a constant
so
raising its graph by adding a constant
or
lowering its graph by subtracting a
constant so maybe the x-axis of this one
is there
the x-axis of this one is there
and the x-axis of this one is there
now once i have told you where the
x-axis is i can tell you when this
polynomial is zero
at least graphically
because the zeros of this cubic
polynomial will just be where its graph
intersects the x-axis
so this one has only a single zero there
this one has only a single zero here
and this one has three of them these
would be the solutions of the equation
uh for example this one
we would have to figure out which of
these three it is but it doesn't matter
we're looking for solutions to equations
of this set so
as i say unless you're really perverse
you either have one or three solutions
and it's in the 16th century that people
began to get formulas equations for the
solutions of cubic
polynomials let us say for the solutions
of when a cubic polynomial of the
problem when a cubic polynomial is zero
now
something
very funny happened
you'd think
this guy has three solutions so it must
be easier to find them because there are
three of them rather than these two
which have only one but it's quite the
reverse
the equations that lead you to uh a
solution for either of these two
are
well
there a bit of algebra
but a bit of algebra that's perfectly um
happily
in the sort of
mental theater
of the 16th century people this one
was a weird weirdy
it was weird uh and in order to s
in order to solve this these are real
numbers
so all you have to do is work in real
numbers this one too you work in real
numbers and you get the solution for
this one something very funny happens i
need another sheet of paper you can have
as many
this is the tuffy and now for this one
of course
the equation for this is real numbers
the solutions
there are three of them
are real and in order to pass
from the cubic equation to the solution
you have to
do
various things
and what
seemed a little perturbing and very in
fact very perturbing to the 16th century
people was this passage you'd have to
pass through a region
which seemed to be out of the as i want
to put it out of the
familiar mental theater
of the mathematicians of the time let us
say imaginary numbers
or complex numbers i'll say imaginary
the mathematicians were perturbed but
not that perturbed
and uh the
first um
recorded
instance of clear perturbation that i
know
is around 1545 cardano
who had to use a certain imaginary
numbers
in fact he had to use the numbers
5 plus the square root of minus 15
and 5
minus the square root of minus 15.
in order to
solve
his equation or to
to deal with uh
this uh issue that he
writes
dismissing mental tortures
and multiplying
5 plus the square root of minus 15
times 5 minus the square root of minus
you get
and he tells you how to do it ul the 5
times 5 is a 25
the square root of minus 15 times the 5
cancels the minus square root of minus
15 times the 5.
the fourth term in these cross terms
that you have to consider is the square
root of minus 15 times minus the square
root of minus 15
which if you work it out is 15
and so you get 25 plus 15 equals 40 and
he writes multiplying 5 plus the square
root of minus 15 by 5 minus the square
root of minus 15 we obtain
25 minus minus 15 and therefore the
product is 40 and thus far does
arithmetical subtlety go
of which
this
the extreme
is
as i have said so
subtle
that it is useless
he's saying that he hasn't yet
gotten into his mathematical repertoire
this strange creature the squared of 15
or
complex numbers in general
and yet
certainly has an intense
understanding
that
we had better begin to deal with it
despite the fact that it may be subtle
and useless
it's the first
instance where someone complains
bitterly and yet uses it such a number
yeah
is that does that still happen now do
you think or or is it or do we complain
bitterly about things that were on the
verge of understanding but not quite
you know
i'm about to say yes
it doesn't matter what
blobs
they are
as long as they're similar the counselor
says yes what do you call that says the
king oh i call that the blob pythagorean
theorem